so when a traditional capital
plans to invest in an opportunity or
considers investing in an opportunity he
or she may predict a range of possible
outcomes and assign a probability to
each of those outcomes to what extent do
you do the same thing when looking to
invest in a impact invest in a company
or make a grant to a non-profit and how
feasible is doing such a thing well I
think that it's see I think it's I don't
know if I would use the word easier but
it's being a traditional investor as you
would use the word you're being measured
by a financial return and it's fairly
easy to measure the financial return if
you're investing in a company you know
what is the profitability of the company
if the company know where if you invest
at a certain level and then you exit at
a certain level what was your return on
capital that's been done for thousands
of years impact investing is new because
it really people used to make grants and
then they would make investments and
it's only been recently and we put it
together and it's complicated because
you can look at the financial return but
that's not why you're making investment
you're making investment because of the
impact as well and i would say that we
probably do the do the same due
diligence and rigor on a pure financial
investment that we do on an impact
investment from the financial side
because it needs to work financially you
have to make a set of assumptions and
you hope that you're going to be within
that range of assumptions from a
financial return on the impact side
there again this is kind of a new area
and there's all these different forms of
measurement i would say on that part we
are less measurement focused so that we
look when we're making investments and
again this is really coming from our
foundation that's making impact
investments and i need to differentiate
that from Mission Point which is a firm
that is focused on financial returns but
making investments in a world of clean
energy in our foundation we are making
investments and we are looking at a
financial return but we also are looking
make an impact the impact that we like
to make is really being a catalyst so
the way we would measure the impact
would be if we made an investment did
other people make an investment
afterwards did we actually test out a
innovative business model was there a
gap in the in the investment
infrastructure of some sort that we
plugged the gap with our small
investment and as a result of that we
proved that a model and other people
came behind us and made a similar
investment that's the way we measure it
if we were successful other people are
coming into the market larger dollars
are coming into the market and
eventually the risks that might have
been associated with the investment we
made will have gone down because
everybody will have proved out the risks
and once the risks go down there's a lot
of capital that can come into the market
people want to come in there just they
have a different risk profile than a
small family foundation